we are in problem 12 I have to take a
pause go ahead a hunger pang but I had
to resist but I do this thing called the
warrior diet which is more of a way of
life anyway back to the s80 back to the
s80 but you shouldn't starve yourself
because you have to feed your brain for
the SCT okay let me draw the X and Y
axis in this in this whatever i'm hungry
i just go outside and do some sprints
that's the warrior way yes the y axis
but you shouldn't do that because you're
probably still growing I unfortunately
have stabilized at five foot nine x
alright so let's see they drew something
that looks like a parabola so I'm going
to assume it is without better
information so let me draw it whoops my
thing does not look like a parabola but
I think you get the point and then they
draw this this rectangle looking thing
I'll Drive another color something like
that
and they let see let me label these
points label the points points q oops q
r s this is T and they say that this is
opie Q P not T and this is point this is
negative one comma 0 so this is you know
obviously the Y is 0 because well in the
x-axis that's negative 1 and that's one
and they ask us okay they tell us so the
figure above PQRS is a rectangle and
point to queue at our line on the graph
of y equals ax squared y is equal to ax
squared and that's this thing is yellow
thing where a is a constant if the
perimeter of PQRS is 10 what is the
value of a so we really need to figure
out is because if we if we can figure
out one ordered pair if we can figure
out 1 XY pair that lie on this curve we
can figure out what the curve is because
we can substitute that Y and X into this
equation and then solve for a well do we
know any points that are on that well
both r and q are on it so if we could
just figure out the coordinates of our
and Q then we will be set so what can we
do well they told us a perimeter they
told us a perimeter of this rectangle so
what do we know about the rectangle
already how long is this side right here
well it goes one unit to the left on the
x axis and it goes one to the right and
it's flat so that has a width of two
right it's a rectangle so if that has a
width of two this also has a width of
two all right let's call this height all
right that's the height of the rectangle
if that's the height that's also the
height so what's the perimeter the
perimeter is two plus two which is four
plus h plus h plus h plus h and that
equals what they told us that equals 10
so we can add those HS together we get 4
plus 2 h is equal to 10 or subtract 4
from both sides to h is equal to 6
divide both sides by 2 h is equal to 3
so we're not H equals 3 so if h equals 3
what is the point r but we know that its
x-coordinate is one out so it's 1 comma
and then what's the y coordinate well
this height right here is 3 all right
we're starting at zero so we go 3 up
from zero so this is going to be 3 right
here so the RS coordinate is 1 comma 3
and r is on the yellow parabola so now
we are set we can take this and
substitute x and y here we know y is
equal to 3 when x is equal to 1 so 1
squared all right x squared so 3 is
equal to a times 1 squared is 1 so a is
equal to 3 because that one doesn't
matter right a is equal to 3 so we just
write down three inside their next
problem next problem problem 1313 if a
times B plus B is equal to a plus to see
what is the value of B when a is equal
to 2a is equal to 2 and c is equal to 3
so real quick thing that we can do just
to maybe simplify things for us is we
can factor out the be on out of the side
and what I mean by factoring out to be
well divide both of these terms by B and
you get B times a plus 1 is equal to a
plus to see rightly box this out so you
don't get confused right all I did is I
undistributed the be all right you can
multiply this back out and you'd get a B
is equal to B and then if you want to
solve for B divide both sides by a plus
one and you get B is equal to a plus to
see over a plus 1 and then you
substitute so a is too so it's 2 plus 2
times c c is 3 2 times 3
over 2 plus 1 which is equal to 2 plus 6
over 3 which is equal to what 8 over 3
another way you could have done it and
it might have been even faster actually
is just a substitute from the beginning
so you say a is too so you get that
would give us to be plus B right I just
days 2 is equal to 2 plus 2 times c2
plus 6 so you get to be plus B so that's
what's to be plus B that's 3b 3b is
equal to 2 plus 68 actually this would
have been faster 8/3 oh those are two
ways you could have done it and
hopefully you'll you'll do them one of
the two ways hopefully you'll do with a
faster way next problem album 14 bunch
of lines for me to draw I do so much for
you guys only thing I get in return is
the satisfaction of you guys getting a
perfect score in the s80 I'm gonna take
these videos down before I have kids
though so they don't have competition
let's see okay I'm kidding the
competition will only make them stronger
I don't have kids yet by the way but one
day I will and they'll have to compete
against you guys who I have given this
edge to that's how selfless I am and
anyway back to the from all right so if
you have this I'm only partially serious
okay this is Elle Elle this is a a a B C
this is angle why why degrees this out
here is angle X X degrees in the figure
above m is parallel to n so this is M
this is n they are parallel fair enough
and l l by sex angle ABC
l by sex angle ABC so what does Vice
ectomy that means that it splits the
angle perfectly so that tells us that
that angle is equivalent to this angle
okay if y is between 45 and 55 y is
between 45 and 55 what is one possible
value for x so let's just say that Y is
50 and see what we can see what we can
do here so if Y is 50 if Y is equal to
50 right that satisfies this is between
45 to 55 what is what is this larger
angle here that I'm going to do in
magenta what is this larger angle what's
a corresponding angle right because it's
a parallel line k is a transversal so
this magenta angle corresponds to Y so
it will also be equal to 50 and we know
L by sex we know L by sex this angle so
both of these smaller angles are going
to be 25 and 25 and now L is a
transversal as well so if L is 25 if
this angle right here is 25 let me do
that in another color I know that color
was too similar to it in red if this
right here is 25 what angle is this
going to be well once again
corresponding angles of a transversal so
this is also going to be 25 and now what
could XB well x is opposite to this
angle so it's also going to be 25
degrees so this was just the angle game
on steroids and you really didn't have
to do the range you can just pick a
number y is 50 corresponding angle is
also 50 that corresponding angle is by
sec did so each of these smaller angles
are 25 and then L is a transversal again
so this is 25 this is 25 and X is
opposite so it's also 25 I'll see you in
the next video